sur le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs et madame la
sénatrice esther benbassa remet pour
vous répondre je voudrais commencer par
rappeler ici les termes de la loi que
vous évoquez est ce fameux article 24
qui fait tant couler d'encre parce que
j'observe que dans les médias les uns et
les autres donnent leur point de vue sur
cet article 20 400 parfois savoir
exactement de quoi il retourne l'article
24 proposée par les députés fauvergue et
tout le monde je rappelle que le député
fauvergue était précédemment un grand
expert du maintien de l'ordre et de la
sécurité qui a donné lieu cet été elle a
de nombreuses consultations cet article
24 ils disent aussi je cite est puni
d'un an d'emprisonnement et de 45000
euros d'amendé le fait de diffuser par
quelque moyen que ce soit et quel qu'en
soit le support
dans le but qu'il soit porté atteinte à
son intégrité physique ou psychique
l'image du visage ou tout autre élément
d'identification d'un agent de la police
nationale ou d'un militaire de la
gendarmerie nationale madame la
sénatrice il sera toujours permis de
filmer des policiers il sera toujours
permis de chine et des gendarmes
il sera toujours ternie d'adresser à la
justice des documents vidéo ce que nous
voulons éviter c'est que ces gendarmes
et ces policiers est une cible dans le
dos et qu'ils aient leurs photos mises
en ligne sur des réseaux sociaux et dans
des médias avec des appels au meurtre d
appel au viol
il est anormal qu'on ait des petit
garçon de 8 ans qui n'ose pas dire à
l'école au moment de la rentrée scolaire
que leur papa y policiers parce qu'ils
ont peur de le mettre en danger
c'est la protection que proposait cette
proposition de loi le débat démocratique
coralliens et j'espère que vous la vôtre
et madame la sénatrice
[Musique]